The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LING REN: So today,
we're going to analyze
two random algorithms we've
seen in the last lecture,
randomized median and
randomized quick sort.
But before I go
into that, I'd like
to make a correction
in problem set two.
I think you all got
feedback from that.
So it's the second
problem, where you're
asked to combine B-trees.
You have two B-trees, T1 and
T2 each with some children.
And we're giving you
another element, k.
And we ask you to combine them.
So if the two trees are the
same height, how do you do that?
Does anyone want to
share his or her answer?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You put k in
the middle of T1 and T2.
And then you can split.
LING REN: Yeah, exactly.
So you put k here.
And if this is too
full, you split.
So why do I have to do this?
Can I simply just make k
my new root and do this?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Because
T1 and T2 don't
have to be valid like
internal [? modular ?] nodes.
LING REN: Yeah, exactly.
So for B-tree, the
requirement on the root
is slightly different
from the requirements
for the rest of the nodes.
To this may have
too few children.
It is not a valid node.
It's not a valid internal node.
But our solution actually made
a mistake in the second part.
In the second part, we're
saying so T1 and T2,
their heights are
different by 1.
Our solution says put k
here and make a pointer.
Exactly the same problem.
Does everyone see that?
So this may not be a
valid internal node.
So what's the correct solution?
You put k here and combine
it with the last child of T1.
And then you may have to
split and split again.
OK.
Everyone happy with that?
Now, today, we're going to look
into randomization specifically
we have seen two
algorithms in class.
I'll just call them quick
find and quick sort.
So quick find is a slightly
generalized version
of medium finding.
In the very first
lecture and recitation,
we have seen a non-randomized
version of quick sort.
So we divide them
into groups of five.
And we find a medium
of each group.
And then find the
median of the median.
Depending on whether you
are smaller or larger,
we drew a funny
subproblem like this.
Anyone remember that?
And we analyzed
this runtime, where
our recursion was one
fifth plus 7 over 10
or something like that.
And we show it's the
worst case O of n.
So that's a smart algorithm,
I'll give you that.
But it's just complicated.
You have to divide
them into groups
and do, well, several
recursive course.
And also, let me
digress a little bit,
there's a very interesting
point regarding this worst case
O of n algorithm.
Has anyone wondered why
we use groups of five?
Why not groups of three?
Algorithms should work
in the same way, right?
If we take out this first
row and this last row,
we can still find the
median, which is just
a second element in
each group and find
the median of the median.
We still have a subproblem
that looks like this.
Exercise.
And it turns out if we
use groups of three,
when we solve the recursion,
it doesn't solve to O of n.
It solves to something else.
OK.
Now, end of digression.
Let's get back to the
randomized version.
So how does the
randomized version work?
It's that much simpler.
We have an array.
Let me call it Find in
array A, which is of size n.
And we want to find i-th largest
or smallest element in it.
So what we're going
to do is that we'll
pick a random element,
x, in this array.
And then we'll put all the
smaller elements on this side
and all the larger
elements on that side.
Now, because I'm
picking the random one,
so this x can be anywhere.
If it is the k-th smallest
element from the left, then
what do I do next?
My goal is to find out
the i-th smallest element
in this array, A.
AUDIENCE: If A is longer
than i then [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: OK.
If i is less than k, then my
element is on this side, right?
So I should find--
OK, let me define
this to be the left array,
this to be the right array.
I should find in the left
array, what is its size?
It's k minus 1.
Make sense?
This is k minus 1.
And that is n minus k plus
one element in the middle.
And so what's the last argument
in that function called?
It's i.
So on the other hand,
if i is greater than k,
then I should go
to my right half.
Its problem size is n minus k.
So what's the last argument?
AUDIENCE: i minus k.
LING REN: Agree?
i minus k.
OK.
So, of course, if i is equal
than k, then we just return x.
Now, obviously, this algorithm's
runtime depends on our luck,
depends on this choice of k.
If k is roughly in the middle,
then we reduce the problem size
by roughly half.
However, if k is
0 or close to n,
then we only reduce the
problem size by a little bit.
So it's impossible to
give a definite runtime.
So what we opt to do
in randomized algorithm
is that we analyze
expected runtime.
What does that mean?
So we can write the
recursion of this.
It's T of n equals-- I
have two subproblems.
One of them is T of k minus 1.
The other is T of n minus k.
So which one should I
put into the recursion?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Yeah.
I don't know, right?
I don't know whether my element
is on a left or on the right.
So I'll be conservative and
take a max of these two.
Let me write it
down a little bit.
And I have some
amount of work to do
before I go to my subproblem.
What's the complexity
of that work?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: It's all O of n.
O of theta n.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because you
have to create the array.
LING REN: Yes.
Because you have to
scan the array once to
put the smaller elements on one
side and the larger elements
on the other side.
Now, this recurrence
is impossible to solve,
because I don't know what k is.
So instead, we'll just
calculate its expectation.
So the expectation of T
of n is taking average
over all the randomness,
which means the choice of k.
So there is a probability
that my k is equal to j.
If my k is equal
to j, then I should
take the maximum of-- sorry.
If my k is equal
to j, then I should
take the expectation of the
maximum between those two.
And according to the
definition of expectation,
I should do a sum from j
equals 0-- no, not zero.
I'm starting with 1 all
the way to n, right?
Any questions so far?
Now, obviously, depending
on my choice of j,
sometimes this one is larger.
Sometimes that one is larger.
I'll just write it
a little verbosely.
So if my j is 1, then I
should take the right one.
Plus, if j is 2, then I
should take m minus 2,
so on and so forth, right?
I think everyone
gets this, right?
So I'll just directly
jump to the next step.
So when j is smaller
than half of n,
I will take the right one.
If j is larger than half
of n, I will take left one.
And they happen to be symmetric.
And what I have here
is-- everyone gets that?
Now, maybe I'm missing
the minus 1 here.
OK, I shouldn't sum to there.
Sorry.
I have n minus 1, n, minus
2, n minus 3, all the way
to half of n.
But from there, I
know longer go down.
I go backwards, half of
n plus 1 plus 2 plus 3,
all the way back to n minus 1.
Any questions so far?
Oh, we forgot our last
term, which is a theta n.
Now, how do we solve this?
Any thoughts?
This is a recurrence on
the expectation of T.
So for this type of
general recurrence,
we don't have a very good way.
Instead, what we'll do is
just take a random guess,
and then see if it is correct.
So I don't really need
to guess in this case,
because I know it's O of n.
So let's just assume
our expectation of Tn
is theta of n.
What does that mean again?
It means I can find
some constant, such
that this expectation is
bounded by a constant times n.
So far so good?
Now, we can use
induction, assume
that this holds for
everything up to n minus 1.
And we're going to show
this also holds for n.
Then we're done, right?
Now, we'll just plug that in.
The expectation of T n will
be less or equal than this sum
from half of n to n.
Right?
Yeah, I just plugged that in.
Of course, plus
our theta n term.
Now, what's the sum of this guy?
Any guesses?
n square? n cube?
or n?
OK.
It's probably a messy.
More cleanly, I can
pull this B out.
It's just the sigma of
j if I change my sum,
decrease the range of sum by 1.
What is the sigma some of j?
What order first?
AUDIENCE: n square.
LING REN: n square.
OK.
Yeah, definitely n square.
But we need to be a little
bit more precise than that.
So what's the coefficient
before the n square?
So I claim this
coefficient is 3 over 8.
Can anyone see that?
AUDIENCE: Why did you assume
that the expected value is
theta n.
LING REN: Oh,
that's just a guess.
If it's wrong, we'll have to
assume something else, which
we'll see in the next example.
But good question.
OK.
Yeah.
Let me ask the question again.
I claim this sum is
roughly 3 over 8 n square.
Can anyone see that?
Any ideas?
So I don't know how to
calculate this term.
But I do know how to calculate
sigma from 1 to n, right?
This is easy.
What's that?
It's half of n, n minus 1.
So it's roughly
half of n squared.
Now, this term is
the sum of this
minus the sum to half of n.
So it's roughly half
of n squared minus one
half of one half n squared.
Makes sense?
So this is roughly 3 over
8 n squared plus an order n
term or less, or constant.
Any questions?
Does that makes sense?
Then it's very easy if
we just plug this in.
Sorry.
There is a mistake.
I just realized.
Can anyone point that out?
So how many terms
do I have in total?
One from n, I have [? a ?] term.
So each term should
appear twice.
Correct?
So I should have a two here.
And so I somehow just throw
away this probability.
But this probability
is 1 over n.
Because I'm choosing
a random element,
there is 1 over n probability
that is equal to 1,
equal to 2, 3, 4.
Every of this is 1 over n.
Correct?
So I should have 2 over
n here, 2 over here.
And if we plug this in, it's 3
over 8 n cubed plus a theta n.
Our goal is to show this is
less than B times n, which
is clearly true.
Because this is 3/4 of n, 3/4
of B times n, plus another term.
We can say this is another
constant D times n.
And if we choose B
accordingly, this can hold.
Any questions?
You look confused or too easy.
OK.
Our guess is the latter.
Oh, it is not?
OK?
So then we have solved this
expected runtime of quick find.
Now, let's look at quick sort.
Quick sort is very similar.
The only difference
is that once I
put all the smaller
elements on one side
and the larger elements
on the other side,
instead of going into one of
them, I have to sort of both.
So the only change is that
instead of taking the max here,
I need to add them.
Correct?
So now the same thing here.
Instead of taking the
max, I should add them up.
Now when it propagates
here, so every term appears
twice all the way from j
equals 1 to j equals n.
Is everyone following?
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat that?
LING REN: Hm-hmm?
LING REN: OK.
Sure.
Originally, we have a max here.
So first, did everyone
get this part?
We have a plus
instead of a max here.
We have to solve
both the problems.
Now, if it's a max, then what
I have is n minus 1, n minus 2,
all the way to half of
n, and then half of n,
half of n plus 1, all the
way back to n minus 1, right?
And if I have a sum, then what
I have is for j equals 1's case,
I have T of 0 and
T of n and minus 1.
This is j equals 1.
If j equals 2, I have T
of 1 and T of n minus 2.
As j increases, this
one goes from 0 to n.
And this one goes
from n minus 1 to 0.
I'm going to sum all of them up.
Does that answer your question?
OK.
So instead of from half of n to
n, we're summing from 1 to n.
Now, we also have another
good question here.
Why do I guess it's theta n?
Well, it's just a random guess.
It could be wrong.
For example, in this
case, it's just incorrect.
Why?
Because every sum, the
range becomes a 1 to n.
Now what I have is no
longer 3 over 8 over n.
What do I have again?
What do I have now
if it's 1 over n?
AUDIENCE: One half.
LING REN: Yeah.
It's one half of n.
But if I change one
half here, what I get
is B times n plus D times n.
I want to prove
that it's smaller
than B times n, which is
clearly impossible no matter
how you choose B.
Did everyone get that?
If we the same assumption,
I make the hypothesis
and we plug them
in, we can no longer
prove the induction step.
OK.
So what we do?
We make another guess.
So let me rewrite our recursion.
So what's the next guess?
Any guesses?
How about we just
guess n square?
Anyone unhappy with that guess?
So we can do the same thing.
We can plug it in.
And that will be a-- sorry,
I missed another term.
This is 1 over 2 here.
If we make that
guess, then what we
have is the sum
from 1 to n minus 1,
the sum of j square
plus a theta n.
And the sum of j squared is
roughly n cubed divided by 3.
Is that obvious to everyone?
Maybe not.
OK.
Can anyone explain
this to us, why
can I claim the sum of square
term is n cubed over 3?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's n times n
minus 1 times n minus 2 over
[INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: I think
you're correct.
There is a formula, which is--
yeah, I don't remember exactly,
but it's roughly this.
If you know this, then
you definitely see that.
If you don't, we can turn
this sum into an integral.
And that is n cubed over 3.
Make sense?
If we plug that in,
what do we have?
2 over n 3n cubed plus theta n.
Of course there's a B here.
And we want to show this is
less than B times n squared.
Does it hold?
Is it true?
It's clearly true, right?
So this-- no.
This is cubed.
Yeah.
Sorry, I am making
many mistakes.
But that's actually good
to catch your attention.
But it actually worries me
that you didn't point this out.
This is 2/3 n
squared times B. It's
clearly less than B n square.
OK.
So we claimed the
algorithm is n squared.
Correct?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Does
that mean that you
claim that it's less
than n squared, being
that it's n squared definitely?
LING REN: Exactly.
So what I've proved here is
that the algorithm is definitely
O of n square, but maybe less.
And you can see we still
have a lot of room here.
This inequality
is not very tight.
So in fact, it's a
very good question,
how do we make that guess.
So you already know the
answer is n log n, right?
So it's not interesting.
But if you don't, then how
do we go about and do things?
We have to make these guesses.
So how about we know this n
doesn't hold and 2 is too much.
Next guess is n raised
to 1 plus epsilon.
Then what will we have?
If we carry out the
same integral argument,
we have 2 plus epsilon, n
raised to 2 plus epsilon
over 2 plus epsilon.
Correct?
And if we plug that
in, we get this.
And we want to show
it's less than n raised
to 1 plus epsilon.
Does this hold?
This term is less than 1.
And that's n raised
to 1 plus epsilon.
So this is true.
So we can easily prove
it's, indeed, n raised to 1
plus epsilon for any epsilon.
Questions?
But is it tight?
We still don't know.
So then what do we do?
We just make another guess.
And let's guess T of n
is [INAUDIBLE] n log n.
Definitely, you may
run into two cases.
You can either prove it or not.
If this doesn't hold, you
just go to log n square.
And gradually, you
will find the answer.
Well, if you don't
know the answer,
probably this is
how you do things.
Now, if we guess
this n log n, then I
have a little harder
equation here.
Because it's now j log j.
How do I compute that?
Yeah.
It's not the sum of natural
number or squares of numbers,
so you cannot use a
formula like this.
But we can still use
the integral argument.
I'm not going to do
that, because that's
what you should have learned in
calculus or other math class.
But it happens that
this integral of j log j
is roughly half of n squared log
n minus some constant times log
n.
I think you can
change this constant.
But it's roughly
smaller than that.
If you plug that in, you get
n over 2 one half times B
plus theta n.
And we want it to be
smaller than B times n log
n, which will be true.
This is exactly that, but
we are minus some term.
And the term we
are extracting is
larger than the theta n term.
So we can prove this
algorithm is n log n.
But you can ask
the same question,
how do I know it's n log n?
Or if I don't know
it's n log n, maybe I
should go about
and try log log n.
So you're welcome to try.
And it's actually a
very good thought.
Because I think is
very uninteresting
if you already know the answer.
If you don't know,
you have to try that.
But when do you stop?
At a reasonable
point, you can also
prove the other way
that it's runtime is
larger than something.
Here, if we prove
this big O of n log n,
if you can show the other
way that it's omega n log n,
then you know you have
arrived at a final answer.
That's the math part.
Any questions about that?
Yeah.
Any questions about
everything I have said so far?
If not, so lastly, I
just have a few comments,
several terminology.
Now, this recitation we
focused on expected runtime.
You have already seen
amortized runtime.
Or you may have heard
of average runtime.
So to be honest,
expected and amortized
are just too fancier
ways of saying average.
But in algorithm analysis, we do
mean slightly different things
with these terms.
So the difference is
that we are averaging
over different things.
So if we say average
runtime, we usually
mean taking the
average over input.
We can imagine a
quick sort of quick
find algorithm that doesn't use
randomness, where you'll always
select your first
element as your favorite.
That's a reasonable algorithm.
If your input is
random, then you
can carry out the same argument
and show that its complexity is
over n or n log n.
But if your input is pre-sorted
or reverse sorted in some
special cases, you
cannot do that.
So average runtime is
usually a very weak argument,
because you have to make
assumptions about your input.
And expected runtime
is definitely better,
because we are taking average
over the randomness we
introduced.
They are independent
of the input.
So we're not making any
assumptions on the input.
So of course, this
comes at a price.
This randomness
doesn't come for free.
So in fact, it's very hard
to generate high quantity
random numbers.
Maybe at the end
of the class, you
will see that in
crypto, a lot of works
are just devoted to generate
high quantity random numbers.
If you can do that
efficiently, you can actually
solve a lot of problems.
So amortized runtime are
slightly, again, different
from these two, because
they are taking average
over a number of operations.
You're doing many, many
operations in a row.
And some of them takes longer.
Some of them take shorter.
And you take average on those.
OK.
That's this recitation.
Any questions?
OK.